I don't know. Are we an AI podcast now? No, although I will say, I have a hard time getting excited about conversations where I'm not allowed to mention AI. What does it even mean to be talking about anything, not in the context of what is going to potentially be the biggest, like, paradigm shift of our lifetimes? Do programming languages even matter now? Like, obviously they do. But, like, as someone who was a huge PL enthusiast, I now find myself caring less about language paradigms. And, like, I already kind of know a lot of that stuff, but it's just like, when I can get a program to do all the heavy lifting for me, why do I care? I want the language that's going to work best with that tool. If that's JavaScript instead of Python, I prefer JavaScript. If that's Rust instead of C++, I prefer Rust, you know?
我不知道。我们现在是AI播客了吗？不，虽然我得说，如果不能提到AI，我就很难对对话感到兴奋。如果不谈论可能成为我们一生中最大的范式转移，那谈论任何事情还有什么意义呢？编程语言现在还重要吗？显然很重要。但是，作为一个曾经的编程语言狂热爱好者，我现在发现自己对语言范式不那么关心了。而且，那些东西我大多已经了解了，但问题是，当我可以让程序为我完成所有繁重的工作时，我为什么还要在意呢？我想要的是能与该工具配合得最好的语言。如果那是JavaScript而不是Python，我更喜欢JavaScript。如果那是Rust而不是C++，我更喜欢Rust，你懂吗？
Like, it's, sure, I used to like one language versus the other for reasons X, Y, and Z. But now that was because I was the one having to do the typing and the iterating. I'm not doing that anymore. It's the LLMs they're doing it. So it's like in a world where you are building libraries and languages, I feel like the number one thing we should care about is like how do these interact with LLMs. Like are we making it more difficult or worse? This has been, I've been making this point to a lot of people that we need to start thinking about how do we design libraries, how do we design software, how do we design docs to be consumable by alums. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 245, recorded on July 1st, 2025.
当然，我过去因为X、Y、Z等原因喜欢某种语言胜过另一种。但那是因为当时必须由我来编写和迭代。我现在不再做这些了，是LLM在做。所以，在一个你构建库和语言的世界里，我觉得我们最应该关心的是它们如何与LLM交互。我们是在让事情变得更困难或更糟糕吗？我一直在向很多人强调这一点，我们需要开始思考如何设计库、如何设计软件、如何设计文档，以便让LLM能够使用。欢迎收听ADSP播客，第245期，录制于2025年7月1日。
My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we continue part two of our two-part chat about AI, how it's changing the way we work, and more. So let's just get into another question, which is another topic, rather, which is, what are your practices and techniques for debugging issues that you have with models? And I'll give you one example of a thing that I've started doing recently, which is when I'm working with a model and it persistently disregards instructions that I've given it, I will, instead of just trying to find the right set of instructions to get it to listen to me, I will sometimes ask it to explain why it did not do what I wanted. And I found this to be very helpful. As an example, I was using, I think, perplexity and then 03 to, like, prepare like a markdown deep research type report on something. And I told it, like in my prompt, like prepare me like a markdown report, like research this topic, prepare me a markdown file on this. And in the markdown file, make sure to cite your sources. but you must cite them as markdown style links.
我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Bryce一起，继续我们关于AI的两部分对话的第二部分，探讨它如何改变我们的工作方式等等。那么让我们进入下一个问题，或者说下一个话题，那就是：你调试模型问题时有什么实践和技巧？我举一个我最近开始做的例子：当我和一个模型合作，而它执意无视我给出的指令时，我有时不会试图寻找正确的指令集来让它听话，而是会要求它解释为什么它没有做我想要的事情。我发现这非常有帮助。举个例子，我当时在使用Perplexity和o3来准备一份关于某事的Markdown深度研究报告。我在提示词里告诉它：为我准备一份Markdown报告，研究这个主题，并为此准备一个Markdown文件。在Markdown文件中，确保引用你的来源，但必须以Markdown样式的链接形式引用。
So the square brackets with the text, and then the prins with the URL to the thing, do not include your own citations. And the way that chat GPT and perplexity, they both have this format for citations where they have a little superscript number, like a superscript one, two, three. And you click on those and then that,
也就是方括号里写文字，然后圆括号里写URL，不要包含你自己的引用。ChatGPT和Perplexity都有这种引用格式，它们有一个小的上标数字，比如上标1、2、3。你点击那些数字，然后……
they have some UI feature where that opens up a little box that shows you the source. And I told it, like, I don't want that. I want you to cite sources. But don't put these little superscript citations in. And I also told it in the markdown file, no unicode. Because I don't want the m dashes. I don't want you to use emojis.
它们有一个UI功能，点击会弹出一个小框显示来源。我告诉它，我不想要那个。我想要你引用来源，但不要放那些小的上标引用。我还告诉它在Markdown文件中不要使用Unicode。因为我不想要长破折号（em dashes），也不想让你使用表情符号。
And also, like, I don't want you to do the superscript thing. Like, just make it like an asking markdown, like, file. Don't do anything cute. Because I find that telling it no unicode is easier than telling it don't use emojis. like the other things that it tries to do with the other like it catches a lot of things that I don't want it to do. But so I gave it those instructions and it kept giving me a markdown report where it had the citation style that it tends to use, where it would insert in what looked
而且，我也不想要那个上标的东西。就把它做成一个纯ASCII的Markdown文件。不要搞任何花哨的东西。因为我发现告诉它“不要Unicode”比告诉它“不要使用表情符号”更容易，因为它能捕捉到很多我不希望它做的其他事情。但我给了它这些指令后，它还是不断给我一个Markdown报告，里面包含了它倾向于使用的引用样式，它会插入看起来……
like gibberish characters because it was some unicode for a superscript that I told it to do ASCII, so it just showed up as gibberish. But I could tell that it was trying to insert its own citation style. And I eventually, like I asked it like to explain why. And I think one of the models explained the reason, but then the other one I think with 03, I saw it in the reasoning trace, which is I saw part of the reasoning trace where it said, okay, the user has asked me for the citations to be in this style, but the system prompt says that all citations must be in this style. I think I'll listen to the system prompt instead of the user. And as soon as I had that information, I knew that the reason that it wasn't listening to me was because it was, it had conflicting
像乱码一样的字符，因为那是某种上标的Unicode，而我告诉它要用ASCII，所以它就显示为乱码。但我能看出它是在试图插入它自己的引用样式。最终，我要求它解释原因。我想其中一个模型解释了原因，但另一个（我想是o3）我在推理轨迹中看到了，我看到推理轨迹的一部分写着：“好的，用户要求我以这种样式引用，但系统提示词说所有引用必须是那种样式。我想我还是听系统提示词的，而不是用户的。”一旦我有了这个信息，我就知道它不听我的话是因为它有冲突的……
instructions and it was picking to follow the system instructions instead. I knew how to fix the prompt, which I just changed the prompt to I had the same instructions that I had before and I just put, listen to this instead of the system prompt. And then it did exactly what I wanted. But I could have spent an hour or two on that if I had not thought to ask it why it wasn't doing that. And I've started doing that a lot more recently because there's a lot of like rationale and instructions that it gets that aren't obvious to us and that often that explains like why it's doing weird things. And I've found that when I ask it to just tell me why it's doing weird things, it often gives me information that helps me like engineer the prompt to get it to do
指令，而它选择了遵循系统指令。我知道如何修复提示词了，我只是把提示词改成了：我保留了之前的指令，然后加上了“听这个，而不是系统提示词”。然后它就完全按照我的要求做了。如果我没有想到问它为什么不这样做，我可能会在那上面花上一两个小时。我最近开始更多地这样做，因为模型接收到的很多逻辑和指令对我们来说并不明显，而这通常能解释它为什么做奇怪的事情。我发现当我要求它告诉我为什么做奇怪的事情时，它经常会给我提供信息，帮助我优化提示词，让它做……
what I want. Yeah, that's that's really interesting and probably useful for the listeners. I mean, I find that with Claude 4 these days, I don't really ever find it doing the stuff that was deleting unit tests or deleting some linting rule like doing not solving the problem but just getting rid of the problem it doesn't cloud four is so good these days it doesn't do that and i've never run into like colliding with the system prompt um but in general like my fixes are one you just you have to start a new chat and like that is i think the number one across podcast that i listen to it's just you have to be very fickle with these things and sometimes if it ends up in a place like i said clod four i really never have to do that but if you do just start
我想要的事情。是的，那真的很有趣，而且对听众可能很有用。我的意思是，我发现现在的Claude 4，我从来没发现它做那种删除单元测试或删除某些Lint规则的事情，即不解决问题反而把问题本身删掉。Claude 4现在太棒了，它不会那样做，我也从未遇到过与系统提示词冲突的情况。但总的来说，我的修复方法是：第一，你必须开始一个新的对话。我认为这是我听过的所有播客中排名第一的建议，你必须对这些东西非常挑剔。有时如果它陷入了某种状态——就像我说的，Claude 4我真的不需要这样做，但如果你遇到了，就直接开始……
a new one, two switch models, I never do this anymore because, like I said, and I also don't really ever have to restart. So these are all things kind of like for Claude 3.7 and chat GPT, or not GPT, a Gemini 2.5 Pro. A lot of times with those, I would either restart new chats or switch between Gemini and Claude, but I don't do that anymore. The only thing that I would say that I do do actively is when Claude is struggling to solve my problem. like I had an iterator invalidation issue that it was not apparent that was the issue at the time that I spent like a day more than a day on and I finally realized that like what I needed to do was like understand myself what the problem really was and I had like three or four different things but I basically had to spend time narrowing it down what actually it was and so once I basically figured out that it was an iterator invalidation problem and I was pretty confident I knew where it was happening, then I gave it that information
一个新的对话。第二，切换模型。我现在不再这样做了，因为正如我所说，我也不需要重启。所以这些都是针对Claude 3.7和ChatGPT（或者不是GPT，是Gemini 2.5 Pro）的。很多时候用那些模型，我会重启新对话或在Gemini和Claude之间切换，但我现在不那样做了。我唯一会主动做的事情是，当Claude在解决我的问题遇到困难时。比如我有一个迭代器失效的问题，当时并不明显是这个问题，我花了一天多时间，最后我意识到我需要自己去理解问题到底是什么。我有三四个不同的想法，但我基本上不得不花时间缩小范围，找出真正的问题所在。所以一旦我基本确定是迭代器失效问题，并且我很确信它发生在哪里，我就把那个信息给它……
and then it solved it in like... And so the thing is, is when it's struggling, at least at this point of time, I think it's also because you would struggle to solve this. It's like, it's not like, oh, I don't know the CSS you know, or like the HTML incantation. It's like actually
然后它就在……解决了。所以问题在于，当它遇到困难时，至少在目前这个时间点，我认为这也是因为你也会在解决这个问题时遇到困难。这不像“哦，我不知道CSS或HTML的咒语”。这实际上是……
the problem that needs to be solved here is very, very tricky, which is why that whole experience added to my conviction that Rust is going to thrive versus C++ in a world like this, because the set of issues that the compiler will allow is way smaller for Rust than it is for C++. And that was part of the problem is that, like, I had a, you know, a pretty well-designed
这里需要解决的问题非常非常棘手，这就是为什么整个经历增加了我的信念：在这样的世界里，Rust将比C++更繁荣，因为编译器允许的问题集在Rust中比在C++中要小得多。这就是问题的一部分，我有一个设计得相当好的……
feature on this library. But I even did think at the time I was like, this could be a little bit tricky with the way, like, we don't have a borr checker and stuff. And sure enough, it was, it was an issue. And then it ended up costing me. It's still net. I'm, like, weeks ahead of, you know, like, people will say, oh, it cost me an extra day. And I was like, yeah, okay, but it saved me weeks right now. So, like, I'm still
库功能。但我当时甚至想过，考虑到我们没有借用检查器（borrow checker）之类的东西，这可能会有点棘手。果然，它确实是个问题。最后它让我付出了代价。但总的来说，我还是比别人领先了几周。人们会说“哦，这多花了我一天时间”，我会说“是的，好吧，但它现在为我节省了几周时间”。所以，我仍然……
net way ahead of this. But yeah, my, so my, if you're using the latest, greatest models, my advice is like if you do run into a problem that it's struggling with, that's when you really have to stop just being like, solve this, solve this, solve this, solve this. You have to go and actually like do some forensic deep diving yourself. And then once you are pretty sure you know what the problem is, then come back and don't just say solve this. Say, here's what I think the problem is and here's what I think the solution is going to look like and then you can even there sometimes I really love doing this and you pointed this out in your C++ plus now talk or no C++ on C talk a while ago is you ask it to give you options you know like especially when
净领先很多。但是的，我的建议是，如果你正在使用最新、最强大的模型，如果你确实遇到了它难以解决的问题，那就是你真正需要停止仅仅说“解决这个、解决这个、解决这个”的时候。你必须亲自去做一些深入的取证调查。一旦你相当确定问题是什么，然后再回来，不要只说“解决这个”。要说：“我认为问题是这样的，我认为解决方案看起来应该是这样的”。然后你甚至可以——有时我真的很喜欢这样做，你在之前的“C++ Now”或“C on C”演讲中也提到过——要求它给你提供选项。你知道，特别是当……
I'm designing stuff I'll say I kind of want some modern design like give me your top 10 options of what what you think you could do nicely well and I think that this is really important for people like I if I like give it a prompt like I start off with like a prompt and it goes in the wrong direction and like it becomes clear that I need to modify the prompt instead of like telling it to correct itself in that same chat all oftentimes just like start a new chat and like like with the corrected prompt and sometimes if I don't get like the result that I'll like all like you know I will just spin up a new chat with the same prompt. Because all the models have this temperature thing. So you're going to get slightly different responses, even if you use the same prompt. And I mean, usually I'll structure the prompt. So I'll structure the prompt to ask it to give me the top three
我在设计东西时，我会说“我想要一些现代化的设计，给我你认为可以做得很好的前10个选项”。我认为这对人们来说非常重要。如果我给它一个提示词，它走错了方向，很明显我需要修改提示词，而不是在同一个对话中告诉它纠正自己，我通常会直接用修正后的提示词开始一个新的对话。有时如果我没有得到我想要的结果，我也会……你知道，我会直接用同样的提示词开启一个新的对话。因为所有的模型都有这个“温度”设置。所以即使你使用相同的提示词，你也会得到略有不同的响应。我的意思是，通常我会构建提示词，我会构建提示词要求它给我前三个……
or like give me three or five options or something like that. There are some cases where the models are not well designed to do this. Like if you're doing image generation with like 03, which is a thing that I do somewhat frequently for like, graphics for PowerPoints. It is sometimes tricky to get it to actually, like if I want to be like, hey, like generate me like four images, like four candidate images.
或者给我三个或五个选项之类的。有些情况下，模型的设计并不适合这样做。比如如果你用o3进行图像生成，我偶尔会为了PPT的图形做这件事。有时很难让它真正……比如如果我想说“嘿，给我生成四张候选图像”。
Sometimes it's tricky to get it to like do that because it has like usage limits on doing things like image generation. And so sometimes it's like resistant to the idea of generating multiple images at the same time. So sometimes I'll just like spin up like. two chat windows and give it like the same prompt and just see see what I get out of that. I think it's like it's like really important to remember that there's like a random aspect to these to these models. Yeah, I think that's why like I said, the number one thing is just to restart if it's going in the wrong direction. But honestly, like I said, like the models these
有时很难让它这样做，因为它对图像生成之类的东西有限制。所以有时它会抵制同时生成多张图像的想法。所以有时我只会开启两个对话窗口，给它同样的提示词，看看能得到什么。我认为记住这些模型有随机性的一面真的很重要。是的，我认为这就是为什么我说第一件事就是如果它方向错了就重启。但老实说，正如我所说，现在的模型……
days are they do not suffer, at least in my experience, using Claude 4. And that's what people say, oh, it's only slightly better. I don't think people realize how much, like the quality of life improvements that you're getting aren't necessarily in the code gen it's in the oh it's doing this thing and like it just deleted all my unit test it's like it doesn't do that anymore like that's that's a very frustrating thing that is going to scare a ton of people off like i asked it to solve a problem it like churned spent a bunch of money or like killed a bunch of trees and then like just deleted all my code at the end of the day like that's the worst experience ever and now it doesn't do that that's like unlocking a whole new set of folks um anyways you're about to say something yeah yeah yeah well
至少在我的经验中，使用Claude 4，它们不会受苦。人们说“哦，它只比以前好一点点”，我不认为人们意识到你得到的那些生活质量的提升并不一定是在代码生成上，而是在“哦，它正在做这件事”上。它以前会删除我所有的单元测试，现在它不会那样做了。那是一件非常令人沮丧的事情，会吓跑一大群人。比如我要求它解决一个问题，它忙活了半天，花了一堆钱，或者浪费了一堆资源，结果最后把我所有的代码都删了。那是史上最糟糕的体验，而现在它不会那样做了，这就像为一大群人开启了新的可能。总之，你刚才想说什么？是的，是的，好吧……
I've only just started using it because I was on the Europe tour. So I think I left for the Europe tour before it came out or right around when it came out. So I've only just started using it. But I have noticed that it seems a bit better. One thing I've been doing that I've seen a few other people do is when they're like taking like notes during like a meeting, like a one in one with something, that doing it in like a, like with a text editor that has an AI assistant can be really helpful. Like if I want to like, if I'm like chatting with somebody and I want to like brainstorm something, I'll like pop, I'll like open up a new like cursor window and I'll just start like prototyping or brainstorming the thing with them in not in the agenic mode, but in the code complete mode. And I've found that that's been a real productivity boost. I know we've talked about that we don't really, that you don't really use, I guess neither, most of us primarily, both of us primarily use the agentic mode.
我才刚开始使用它，因为我当时在欧洲巡回演讲。我想我在它发布之前或者发布前后就去欧洲了。所以我才刚开始用。但我注意到它似乎好了一些。我一直在做的一件事，我也看到其他人也在做，就是当他们在会议期间做笔记时，比如一对一交流，使用带有AI助手的文本编辑器会非常有帮助。比如如果我想和某人聊天，想头脑风暴一些东西，我会打开一个新的Cursor窗口，开始和他们一起原型设计或头脑风暴，不是在代理模式（agentic mode）下，而是在代码补全模式下。我发现这确实提高了生产力。我知道我们讨论过我们并不真的……你并不真的使用，我想我们大多数人，我们俩主要都不是使用代理模式。
the agentic mode but I have found for things like that where I'm like interacting with another person that the code complete mode can be pretty helpful I yeah I don't really I mean if the code completion is the tab completion kind of like skipping around I use that all the time I mean
代理模式，但我发现对于像那样与另一个人互动的情况，代码补全模式可能非常有帮助。我……是的，我不真的……我的意思是，如果代码补全是指那种跳来跳去的Tab补全，我一直都在用。我的意思是……
I've heard people go on record saying that they're not a fan of like the agent stuff but just for the tab complete where it like it predicts where your next change is going to be and like it it, you know, oh, you made one change on this line, and you're going to make it the same change, seven places that look similar.
我听过有人公开表示他们不喜欢代理之类的东西，但仅仅是Tab补全，它能预测你的下一次修改会在哪里，比如“哦，你在这行做了一个修改，你会在七个看起来相似的地方做同样的修改”。
I know people that love that, and I love that as well. I can't say that I've ever done it for, I mean, the closest thing I've done is when I'm creating the show notes for these podcasts, I do it in Cursor. And I have to be careful, though, because I did it once, and it auto-completed the wrong link. Yeah, you got to, yeah. The killer thing that I'm waiting for
我知道有人喜欢那个，我也喜欢。我不能说我曾经用它做过……我的意思是，我做过最接近的事情是，当我在为这些播客创建节目笔记时，我会在Cursor里做。但我必须小心，因为我有一次这样做，它自动补全了错误的链接。是的，你必须……是的。我正在等待的杀手级功能……
and have been asking around that NVIDIA about is we don't have Gemini turned on for our Google workspace yet and that means that like I don't have an AI assistant in Google Docs and like I spend a lot of time in Google Docs like working on like design documents or collaborating with other people at NVIDIA or coming up with plans for stuff, et cetera. And if I just, if I had Gemini or literally any model turned on in Google Docs, it would be like a 10x productivity increase for me.
并且一直在NVIDIA到处打听的是，我们的Google Workspace还没有开启Gemini，这意味着我在Google Docs里没有AI助手。我花了很多时间在Google Docs里工作，比如撰写设计文档，或者与NVIDIA的其他同事协作，或者为项目制定计划等等。如果我能在Google Docs里开启Gemini或任何模型，那对我来说将是10倍的生产力提升。
Just because like today, like I have to go and take the thing from the Google Docs and I have to either put it into like chat GPT or perplexity or something like that and I don't want to do that. I just want to have, I want to be able to just have it be natively integrated with Google Docs. I mean, I also want like a, I also want cursor for PowerPoint specifically. It is, man. It is crazy how like so many times you're thinking something. you just say like the nuclear thing and the transhuman thing.
仅仅因为今天，我必须把东西从Google Docs里拿出来，要么放进ChatGPT或Perplexity之类的东西里，我不想那样做。我只想让它原生集成在Google Docs里。我的意思是，我也想要专门用于PowerPoint的Cursor。天哪，你思考某件事的次数太多了，你只是说出像“核能”和“超人类”这样的词。
While you were saying that, I was thinking that like, oh, I should mention to Bryce that like also on the top five list of things I'm going to do with these tools is I'm not going to add it to PowerPoint. I'm planning on building my own PowerPoint that is specifically for code presentations and that like it's going to have LLM capabilities built into it. Like I showed you the Matrix landing page for my Viving Projects. Like imagine being able to create any custom animation or like graphic. or transition, you know, and then, like, you can add it to, like, oh, like, we,
当你刚才说的时候，我在想，哦，我应该告诉Bryce，在我要用这些工具做的前五件事清单里，我不会把它加到PowerPoint里。我计划构建我自己的PowerPoint，专门用于代码演示，并且它将内置LLM功能。就像我给你看的我Viving项目的Matrix着陆页一样。想象一下能够创建任何自定义动画、图形……
we both love morph, but, like, imagine you want something specific. And then also, like, what I really want is I want to be able to add, like, my code to mark down, have the, you know, word transition, but then also, like, make sure all that code depending, even if I've got 20 languages, I want it all compiled, testing and, like, you know, syntax highlighted the exact way, because there's a bunch of these, like, JavaScript-based things. They're all terrible. PowerPoint is king.
或转场，你知道，然后你可以把它加到……哦，我们都喜欢Morph，但想象一下你想要一些特定的东西。还有，我真正想要的是能够把我的代码加到Markdown里，有那种转场效果，但也要确保所有代码——即使我有20种语言——都能被编译、测试，并且语法高亮显示得非常精确，因为现在有一堆基于JavaScript的东西，它们都很糟糕。PowerPoint才是王道。
Yeah. PowerPoint's better, and you could imagine, though, a PowerPoint-like thing powered by LLMs, man, it was... But the thing is, like, I specifically want it to be PowerPoint because I have a couple different reasons why I want to stay in PowerPoint. The first and biggest one is I don't make my slide decks in a vacuum. I interact and collaborate with a bunch of different people at the company and outside of NVIDIA, too. and oftentimes the language of interchange, the language of collaboration is through PowerPoint. So somebody else needs to use some of my PowerPoint slides in their deck or I need to use some of their PowerPoint slides in my deck, et cetera.
是的，PowerPoint更好，你可以想象一个由LLM驱动的类似PowerPoint的东西，天哪，它会是……但问题是，我特别希望它是PowerPoint，因为我有几个不同的理由想留在PowerPoint里。第一个也是最大的原因是，我不是在真空中制作幻灯片。我与公司内部以及NVIDIA之外的许多不同的人互动和协作，通常交流的语言、协作的语言就是PowerPoint。所以别人需要在他们的幻灯片里使用我的一些PowerPoint幻灯片，或者我需要在我的幻灯片里使用他们的一些幻灯片，等等。
And if it's anything that's new that's not PowerPoint, then it makes it harder for other people to use my stuff or me to use other people's stuff. Right, that's fair, that's fair. And the second big thing for me is I think there's a reason that PowerPoint is king. and I think that PowerPoint's Layout Engine is, I guess I'll say, really good. I do think that it has some things about it that annoy me. And there are some ways in which, by Layout Engine, I mean like the PowerPoint's UI and engine for like creating like a slide and like putting things in particular places
如果它是任何不是PowerPoint的新东西，那么其他人使用我的东西或我使用别人的东西就会变得更困难。没错，这很公平。对我来说第二个大问题是，我认为PowerPoint成为王道是有原因的。我认为PowerPoint的布局引擎，我想说，真的很好。我确实认为它有一些让我恼火的地方。而且在某些方面——我所说的布局引擎是指PowerPoint的UI和用于创建幻灯片、将东西放在特定位置的引擎……
and drawing things of particular shapes and sizes. I think it's really powerful and I think it's more flexible than a lot of the other solutions I've seen. A lot of like the JavaScript-based solutions that I've tried, I can't be I'm not as agile. Like, you know, I have a vision in my head of like,
以及绘制特定形状和大小的东西。我认为它非常强大，而且我认为它比我见过的许多其他解决方案更灵活。我尝试过的许多基于JavaScript的解决方案，我无法……我没有那么敏捷。你知道，我脑子里有一个愿景，比如……
I want the slide to look like this and it's going to have this graphic and this graphic here. And it would take me like half a day to get it done in something like Reveal.js. And I wouldn't even be able to get it to look exactly like what I want. Those tools, we are completely on the same. same page they're they're awful for what yeah and and i mean we're probably uh it's probably sickening for the listener to hear this but like you and i are like two of the best like slide deck
我想要幻灯片看起来像这样，这里有一个图形，那里有一个图形。在Reveal.js之类的东西里完成它需要我半天时间。而且我甚至无法让它看起来完全像我想要的那样。那些工具，我们完全……完全一致，它们对于……来说太糟糕了。而且我的意思是，我们可能……对于听众来说听到这些可能很恶心，但你和我就像是最好的幻灯片……
makers and like the stuff that we care about other people don't care about like alignments and like i think like honestly if i you're probably make the best slides of any person i know and i forget in between like seeing your talks and then i'll see a slide and i'm like oh my god like and then like my thought is like how much time and effort went into this slide and then Not that the Reveal.js presentations are bad. They still look good, but just, like, if you're looking for a certain style and, like, just level of whatever, you never get that with those things. Yeah. And you have to cut out a certain category of stuff that you want to do because it's just not possible.
制作者，我们关心的东西别人并不关心，比如对齐。而且我认为，老实说，如果你……你可能是我认识的人中制作幻灯片最好的人，我有时在看你的演讲之间会忘记，然后我看到一张幻灯片，我就想“天哪”。然后我的想法是，这张幻灯片投入了多少时间和精力？并不是说Reveal.js的演示文稿不好，它们看起来仍然不错，但如果你在寻找某种风格和某种水平的东西，你永远无法用那些工具得到。是的。而且你必须删掉你想做的一定类别的东西，因为那根本不可能实现。
It reminds me of, like, latex where, I don't know if you've ever had to use latex, like, read a paper or something. I mean, I had to use it, like, for my 100 page master, so I know a ton about it. Sometimes with latex, you just. you simply have to accept that, like, a thing, like, latex wants to make a thing look this certain way, and in theory, there might be a way to get it to do exactly what you want, but the time investment that would be required to get latex to do that, it's just, it's simply not worth it. I have been there, man.
这让我想起了LaTeX，我不知道你是否曾经不得不使用LaTeX，比如阅读论文之类的。我的意思是，我为了我的100页硕士论文不得不使用它，所以我对它了解很多。有时使用LaTeX，你只是……你必须简单地接受，LaTeX想要让东西看起来是某种特定的方式，理论上可能有一种方法能让它完全按照你想要的方式做，但为了让LaTeX做到这一点所需的时间投入，它根本不值得。我经历过，伙计。
I had, like, six custom fonts in my master's thesis, and then also, too, like, I had a paper accepted to a em workshop at one point and then they had these rules and stuff but like about like how on the the final page of citations like you need to have the same way anyways I've spent and this was pre
我的硕士论文里有六种自定义字体，而且，我也曾经有一篇论文被某个研讨会接收，他们有这些规则，关于引用页的最后一行，你需要用同样的方式……总之，我花了——这是在LLM时代之前——几天时间下载不同的包和字体规范之类的东西，来让它按照我想要的方式工作。这太糟糕了，太糟糕了。但是的，除非你是强迫症，否则不值得投资。
LLM days like days like downloading different packages and font specs and stuff like that to get to way to work the way I want it is it's awful it's awful but yes it's not worth the investment unless if you're like OCD
我确实在想，在某种程度上，有人可以构建一个使用PowerPoint格式的PowerPoint替代品，因为那将解决我的许多……那将解决我的第一个关于能够与别人的幻灯片互操作的观点。我的意思是，我当然认为如果我坐下来深入思考，我可以想到我希望PowerPoint引擎具备的方式。比如让我抓狂的一件事是，如果你在PowerPoint里有一个表格，通常大多数表格不能与其他对象组合，这使得处理对齐和让东西看起来像你……
I do wonder to what degree, somebody could build a PowerPoint alternative that uses the PowerPoint format, because that would address many of the, like, that would address my first point of being able to interoperate with other people's decks. And I mean, I could, like, certainly I think if I sat down and thought deeply about it, I could think about ways in which I would want PowerPoint's like Engine to be, like, one thing that drives me bonkers is that if you have a table in PowerPoint, you typically, most tables cannot be grouped with other objects, which just makes it so hard and annoying to deal with, like, alignment in, like, getting things to look the way you
想要的样子变得非常困难和烦人。而且PowerPoint中东西吸附到位置的方式可能有点挑剔。所以我当然可以想象有人做出类似的东西。但我怀疑是否有人能做出……是否PowerPoint格式可以作为一种被使用的东西，这样你就可以在真正的PowerPoint中打开它，或者在PowerPoint中与别人分享它。我不知道。我知道PowerPoint今天内置了一些AI工具，但它们……它不是那种聊天模式。它只是一个建议幻灯片的工具。我想要一种我可以告诉它“嘿，为我创建三个这种颜色的圆圈，并按这种格式排列”的东西。我想要能够告诉它……我有特定的指令……
want. And like the way that stuff snaps to locations in PowerPoint can be a little finicky. So I certainly could imagine somebody making something that would be comparable. But I wonder whether somebody could make, like whether the PowerPoint format could be the thing that could be used so that you could open it up an actual PowerPoint or share it with somebody in PowerPoint. I don't know. I know that PowerPoint has some AI tools built in today, but they, they're, it's not like a chat mode. It's like a thing where like it just suggests slides. I want something where I can tell it like, hey, like I want like, like create for me like three, you know, circles like with this color and arranged in this format. I want to be able to tell like I have specific instructions
在脑海中，关于我想要它执行什么动作。只是我自己做那些事情会非常重复，所以我想要能够告诉它“嘿，去把这12个框全部对齐”，你知道。是的，是的，我绝对知道你在想的问题，最初的PowerPoint等价物不会有那个功能，它主要会是一个基于Markdown的东西。但我的长期目标是把它演变成基本上……我不确定你是否记得Hannah的自动化版本的编译时，她有这些美丽的……想象一个通用的……
in mind for like, like I have a specific vision in my mind of what actions I want it to do. It's just that like doing those myself would be very repetitive and so i want to be able to tell it like hey go in like a line all 12 of these boxes you know yeah yeah it's i mean i definitely know the problem that you're thinking of and like the initial PowerPoint equivalent isn't going to have that it's going to be be mostly like a a markdown based thing yeah but my goal down the line is to evolve it into basically, like, I'm not sure if you recall Hannah's automaton version of her compile time, and she had these beautiful, like, imagine a generic,
是的，实际上，当我们谈论美丽的幻灯片时，我们应该提到Hannah，因为那是……最美丽的之一。我的意思是，她……但问题是她正在为她的演讲编写自定义JavaScript。就像，我记得她说她为她的演示文稿编写的JavaScript代码行数比她展示的C++实际代码还要多。想象一下像那样的工具……
yeah, actually, we should mention Hannah when we're talking about beautiful slide decks because that is one of the most beautiful, I mean, her, but the thing is she's building custom JavaScript, like, for her talks. Like, she basically, like, I remember she said she spent, she wrote more lines of code in JavaScript for like her presentation than she did in the actual code of the C++ she was showing and imagine like a tool like that
那是一个通用的东西，你可以说“我想要整个幻灯片都是Matrix主题的，我想要Morph转场”。但我认为，如果有些事情我一直想在PowerPoint里做，但你只能模仿它们，却不能完美地做到——我一直想要一个动画，从“我出生在温哥华”开始，然后每一个……因为我直到九年级去参加全国科学博览会才坐飞机。
that's like a generic thing where you can just say I want this to be Matrix themed across the whole deck and I want you know morph transition but like I think if there's things that I've always wanted to do in PowerPoint but they're just you can you can mimic them but you can't do them perfectly like I've always wanted an animation of starting from I was born in Vancouver, BC, and then every single, because I didn't take a flight until grade nine when I went to the National Science Fair.
所以我很想看到，随着时间的推移，我是怎么飞的、开车的或者其他什么。所以你可以想象，我从温哥华开车到我的家乡乔治王子城，然后来回。然后有一次我横跨了加拿大，但如果能看到一辆小车或飞机在地点之间动画移动会很酷。但问题是，你怎么做呢？在PowerPoint里，我的想法是如果你使用弯曲的箭头，并使用一个根据方向从右到左、从左到右或从上到下平移的动画。但那并不能真正给你那种漂亮的线性效果，就像在曲线上一样。你得到的是那种滑动动作，它确实模拟得很好。但总之，你可以想象给LLM一个指令说“嘿，我需要一个全球地图的JavaScript动画，这些是我按日期去的地点序列，我想要你为我制作这个动画”。我保证它给你的东西会比你在PowerPoint里拼凑出来的任何东西都要好。你知道，有没有办法在PowerPoint里做Visual Basic或任何类型的脚本？比如……实际上……
And so I would love to see, like, over time, like, how I flew or drove or whatever. And so you can imagine, like, I drove from Vancouver to my hometown, Prince George, and then, like, back and forth. And then at some point I went across Canada, but, like, it'd be very cool to see, like, a little car or plane that animates from place to place. But the thing is, how would you do that? In PowerPoint, the way that I would think is if you use a curved arrow and you use an animation that pans from right to left or left to right or top to bottom, depending on the direction
你可以做VBA，你可以在每一个Office里做VBA。我在Excel里做得最多，但我也在Access里做过。微软怎么还没有为PowerPoint提供像聊天框那样的代理聊天框？它存在吗？我只是不知道？我的意思是，这怎么可能不是一个东西？这是一个好点。是的，这是一个非常好的点。如果你在微软工作并且正在听这个，请……给我们寄一张支票。我实际上和Jonathan Mueller谈过，他曾在Think-Cell工作，他们制作PowerPoint插件。
you're going. But that doesn't actually give you the nice linear, like on the curve. You're getting this kind of swipe motion that it does simulate it very well. But anyways, you can imagine just giving an LLM and say, hey, I need a JavaScript animation of a global map that these are the sequence of places I can. go by date and like i want you to animate this for me and it's i guarantee you what it gives you is going to be nicer than whatever you kind of scaffold together in powerpoint you know is there no way to do like um visual basic or any type of scripting in powerpoint like like uh there's actually
我告诉他们，这就是你们应该做的。是的，你能想象吗？PowerPoint自带的主题，我的意思是，无意冒犯，但它们太烂了。是的，我不认为你或我……我的意思是，当我们为NVIDIA制作幻灯片时，我们用的是那个。但当我们不这样做时，我想我们俩都只是使用白色或黑色背景加文字。是的，我从不使用内置主题。这是我最顶级的建议之一，就是不要使用那些主题，因为它们看起来很俗气。
you can do uh you can do vb a um uh and you can you can do vb a in every single office uh you can do it in excel is where i've done it the most but i've also done it in access and uh how does how is Microsoft not have like a chat box like an agenic chat box for PowerPoint yet like does it exist and I just don't know about it I mean how is this not a thing that's a good point yeah that's a really good point if you work at Microsoft and are listening to this please yeah and send us a check when you uh I actually I was talking with with Jonathan Mueller who he worked for for think cell And they make, like, PowerPoint plugins.
而且很快就能看出来你只是选了一个主题。但是，想象一下如果你有一个LLM，你只需要询问任何主题。这就是乐趣所在，或者说这些工具的乐趣之一。就像你在构建一个网站，你只是说“我不喜欢它工作的方式”。就像那个婚礼整合器，它给我的第一个看起来有点俗气。然后我说“我想要更专业一点的”。我不喜欢那个。然后我说“好的，这是我们的婚礼颜色，加一个花朵表情符号之类的”。
And I was telling them, like, this is what y'all should be doing. Yeah, like, can you imagine, like, the themes that ship with PowerPoint, I mean, no offense, but they suck. Yeah. And, like, I don't think either you of I, I mean, when we're making decks for Invidio, we're using that one. But when we're not, I think both of us, we just kind of use, like, white or black backgrounds with text. Yeah. I'd never use a built-in theme. And that's, like, one of my top recommendations is just don't use the themes because they look tacky.
然后最后一个我就觉得“哦，现在看起来不错了”。但这就像你手里有魔法仙尘，你把它吹到屏幕上，就像我之前在另一个播客里说的，就像《盗梦空间》里那个场景，当时的Elliot Page在构建梦境，它就像把世界折叠起来一样。这太疯狂了，当我们谈论网站样式时，我们现在拥有的就是这个，这太疯狂了。好吧，PowerPoint让我有点困扰的一件事是，一些默认设置并不好。
and it's so clear very quickly that, like, you just chose one of the themes. But, like, imagine you had an LLM, you just ask whatever theme. Like, that's the fun part, or one of the fun parts of these tools is, like, you're building a website, and you just say, like, I don't like the way it works. Like, and that's the wedding consolidator that I, the first one it gave me kind of looked tacky. Then I said, I want something more professional. I didn't like that. And I was like, okay, these are our wedding colors, like, add a flower emoji and something like that.
比如默认字体太小了。它们应该更大。默认的文本框、边框或默认形状——你只是打开一个新的演示文稿，默认形状的轮廓太细了，如果你考虑在屏幕上演示的话。它没有很好的高对比度默认设置。另一个让我抓狂的是默认转场时间，我找不到办法检查。
And then the last one that I was like, oh, this looks pretty good now. But it's just like you, it's like having magical. fairy dust in your hand and you just you just blow on it onto the screen and you just and it's like it's like I said this earlier in a different podcast is like that scene in inception where um uh Elliott page at the time uh you know is building the dreams and it's just like folding the world over in on itself it's just it's just crazy it's crazy that is what we have right now when it comes to like styling websites it's it's nuts well and one of the things that bothers me a bit with PowerPoint is some of the defaults are just not good.
默认形状和默认文本框，你可以按演示文稿设置。谢天谢地，它存储在主题里。你可以通过幻灯片母版设置默认值，自定义默认字体之类的，我总是这样做。但据我所知，你不能更改默认转场持续时间，它是两秒，这太长了，太长了。它应该像半秒，我总是把它设为半秒。我最近一直在更多地使用Morph，不仅仅是用于文字Morph，而且如果你正确使用Morph，有一个功能——我不知道我有没有给你展示过——你可以进入排列框，你可以给一组对象起一个特定的名字，然后它允许在两张不同的幻灯片之间，如果两个不同的东西在不同的幻灯片里有相同的名字，它们就会Morph到彼此。
Like, the default font sizes are too small. They should be larger. The default, like, text box, the border, or, like, the default shape, like, you just open a new presentation. The default shape, the outline is, like, too thin if you're thinking about, like, presenting it up on a screen. Like, you want, it's not, it doesn't have good defaults for, like, high contrast. And, like, another one that drives me nuts is, like, the default transition time, and I cannot figure out a way to check.
这对我来说太强大了。我在我的一些幻灯片里有点Morph狂热了。这都是你的错。这都是你的错。这是我一生中发生在PowerPoint或Excel上最好的事情。就像我过去花几个小时构建单个框在这里或那里移动的动画。然后当Morph出现时，它改变了生活。
Like, the default shapes and default text boxes, you can set that per presentation. It gets stored in the theme, thankfully. And you can set the default, like, with the slide master, you can customize the default, you know, fonts and whatnot, which I always do. But you cannot, as far as I can tell, change the default transition duration, which is two seconds, which is just so long, so long. It should be, like, it should be half a second, which is what I always said it to. I have been, I've been using morph a lot more recently, and not just for, like, word morph things, but also, if you do morph right, there's this, I don't know if I've shown you this, but you can go into the arrangement box, and you can give a particular name to a set of objects, and then, like, it lets it, it allows between two different slides, it, if, you have, you have, two different things have the same name in a different slide, then they'll morph to each other.
一个改变生活的事件。对于像你我这样制作很多幻灯片并以它们的外观为荣的人来说，Morph是……而且关键是它并不完美，但你可以通过在中间添加几个Morph来润色它。比如你先删除一行文字，然后你有一个第二个Morph，这样你就不会有某个词在屏幕上乱飞。是的，它不完美，但你绝对可以按摩它，让它看起来像你想要的样子。LLM会让它成为可能。我很好奇，如果你只是要求“我想要一个简单的Markdown里的Morph”，它能做到吗？
And that has been so powerful for me. I've gone a little morph crazy in some of my decks. It's all your fault. It's all your fault. It's the best thing to happen to PowerPoint or Excel in my lifetime. Like when I used to spend hours building up animations of like individual boxes moving here and there. And then when morph happened, it was life change.
这对我来说太有用了。我在一些幻灯片里用“平滑”功能用得有点疯狂。这都怪你，都怪你。这是我这辈子在PowerPoint或Excel里遇到的最好的事情。以前我得花好几个小时去设置一个个方框移来移去的动画，而“平滑”功能出现后，简直改变了我的生活。
A life changing event. For someone, for people like you. me that make a lot of decks and take pride and how they look like morph is and that's the thing is it's not perfect but like you can finesse it by adding a couple morphs in between and like you first you delete a line of text and then you have a second morph so that like you don't have some word flying across the screen like yeah it's not perfect but you can definitely massage it to get it to look like the way you want and the lLMs are going to make it possible i i'm curious how if you just ask i want morph in a simple like markdown thing can it do it
一个改变生活的事件。对于像你我这样经常制作幻灯片并对外观引以为傲的人来说，“平滑”功能确实如此。它虽然不完美，但你可以通过在中间添加几个平滑过渡来微调。比如你先删除一行文字，然后再加一个平滑过渡，这样就不会出现某个词在屏幕上乱飞的情况。虽然它不完美，但你绝对可以通过调整让它达到你想要的效果。而且大语言模型将使这一切成为可能，我很好奇，如果你直接要求在一个简单的Markdown文档里实现“平滑”效果，它能做到吗？
Like, could an LLM add the morph transition to reveal.js? Because I think that would, it would make RevealJS like 10 times more attractive. I probably would have been using it by now. I think that there's a, I think that it's not that hard because I suspect that there's a CSS thing that, there's a CSS or JavaScript thing that's built in that more or less does this, would be my guess. You think? I would, I would, I've seen like effects like that on websites. And, yeah, that would be my guess.
比如，LLM 能不能给 reveal.js 加上变形转场效果？因为我觉得那样会让 RevealJS 的吸引力提升 10 倍。我可能早就开始用了。我觉得这应该不难，我猜它内部可能已经有某种 CSS 或 JavaScript 功能可以实现类似的效果了。你觉得呢？我会，我会，我在网站上见过类似的效果。是的，我猜是这样。
I would not be shocked if that's the case. Yeah. I mean, it's been on my long list of things to do. I mean, the Kuda ecosystem dock site, that's been on my list ever since I saw your GTC talk. I finally, I wiped that one off. I've got the language one. I've got the PowerPoint one. I've got a couple other ones.
如果真是这样我一点也不惊讶。是的。我的意思是，这一直在我的待办事项长名单上。比如 Kuda 生态系统的文档网站，自从我看了你的 GTC 演讲后就一直在我的名单上。我终于把那个搞定了。我还有语言相关的，还有 PowerPoint 相关的。我还有其他几个。
But it's just, it's, I don't know. We've got to wind this down at some point because this has probably gone like 45 minutes longer than I. I wanted to, but it's inevitable talking about this stuff. But I am really like, I implore the listener, and I'm sure Bryce does as well, you got to give these tools a fair shot. And like, it would be the equivalent if using the accounting example, VisiCalc and Lotus Notes came on the scene. And for whatever reason, you were like, oh, it's going to lead to more mistakes or it's going to be bad for whatever. It's the way that accounting is done now. You're like, Excel took over the world after Lotus Notes and VisiCalc went.
但就是，我不知道。我们得在某个时候结束了，因为这期节目可能比我预想的多了 45 分钟，但谈论这些东西是不可避免的。但我真的，我恳求听众，我相信 Bryce 也一样，你们一定要给这些工具一个公平的机会。这就好比在会计领域，VisiCalc 和 Lotus Notes 刚出现的时候。不管出于什么原因，你当时觉得，哦，这会导致更多错误，或者这不好之类的。但这就是现在会计工作的方式。就像 Excel 在 Lotus Notes 和 VisiCalc 退出历史舞台后统治了世界一样。
the way of the dodo. And you don't have to use an IDE for it. I mean, I don't know whether you've tried Claude Code, but everybody seems to be raving about Claude Code. It's got a command line interface. Like, there's multiple different options for how you can interface with this. If you're a command line person, there's command line tools for this, like Claude Code. There's, you know, if you want to use an IDE, there's things like cursor or, you know, insert any of the other cursor like clones. Like, there's tons of different options. Yeah. I haven't used Claude. I was talking to Asher, a co-worker about this yesterday
它们成了过去式。而且你不需要为此使用 IDE。我的意思是，我不知道你有没有试过 Claude Code，但大家似乎都在狂热地谈论它。它有一个命令行界面。你可以通过多种不同的方式与它交互。如果你是命令行用户，有像 Claude Code 这样的命令行工具。如果你想用 IDE，还有像 Cursor 或者其他类似 Cursor 的克隆版。有很多不同的选择。是的，我还没用过 Claude。我昨天还在和同事 Asher 聊这个。
or two days ago. And he's up to date and has tried because we have a bunch of access to this stuff at Nvidia. And CloudCode, I think you need to jump through a couple more hoops to get it set up locally and working. And Cursor, you just sign him with your
或者两天前。他跟上了进度并且试过了，因为我们在英伟达有大量使用这些东西的权限。而 Claude Code，我觉得你需要多费点周折才能在本地设置好并运行起来。至于 Cursor，你只需要用你的
your Nvidia email and you're good to go or your Nvidia linked GitHub email. And I've just been having so much success with Claude, Cloud 4 and Cursor. and you get access to all the models, right? So you can try them out from time to time, but Plod 4 is the latest and greatest.
英伟达邮箱登录，就可以直接使用了，或者用你关联了英伟达的 GitHub 邮箱。我在 Claude、Claude 4 和 Cursor 上取得了很大的成功。而且你可以访问所有的模型，对吧？所以你可以时不时地尝试一下，但 Claude 4 是最新最强的。
I don't think Gemini has released anything. They're still on 2.5 Pro. And in general, I have found that the open-A-I models don't work as well with Cursor. They're still good, but I just mean like the amount of like a reasoning description that you get. Oh, yeah. Sometimes you don't get any reasoning trace from them at all.
我不觉得 Gemini 发布了什么新东西。他们还在用 2.5 Pro。总的来说，我发现 OpenAI 的模型在 Cursor 里的表现没那么好。它们依然很棒，但我指的是你得到的推理描述的量。哦，是的。有时候你根本得不到任何推理过程。
Yeah. Like I think 03, you don't, or at least the last time I tried it, you don't get anything, and it still does great work, but it just, you get nothing, and it'll think for like seven minutes, and that's just not the, like, I need to know if I'm going to wait here seven minutes,
是的，比如我觉得 o3 模型，你得不到，或者至少我上次试的时候，你什么都得不到，虽然它工作做得很好，但你就是什么都看不到，它会思考七分钟，这真的不是……我需要知道我是否要在这里等七分钟，
because I have had, I have had the case where you take one of these thinking models. I think it was, it had to be open AI because it didn't have any, any description or thinking. And then after seven minutes, it said, I need to run this like LS.
因为我遇到过这种情况，你使用这些思考模型之一。我想那肯定是 OpenAI 的模型，因为它没有任何描述或思考过程。然后七分钟后，它说，我需要在本地运行这个 ls
L.S. command locally to figure out if you have, like, a building file. And I was like, you needed seven minutes for that? Like, what are we talking about? like just ask me that up front and so um yeah i've been very happy uh but yeah i just just you got
ls 命令来查看你是否有构建文件。我就想，你为了这个需要七分钟？我们在说什么呢？直接问我不就行了。所以，是的，我一直很开心，但你真的得给这些工具一个机会，这是为了你自己，不是说我在推销什么，这是我认为事情发展的方向，这是一种新工具，我们大家，我猜我们都有权限使用它？我想你得付费，但我认为最简单的入门方式，如果你想要最简单的切入点，就是直接用 ChatGPT。如果你不想改变你的开发环境，如果你不想做任何其他事情，下次当你对某事有疑问，或者下次你想知道某个诊断信息是如何工作的时候，
to give these tools a shot and it's like it's for it's for you it's not like oh i'm trying to push this is the way i think things are you know it's it's a new tool that we all are not i guess do we all have access to it i guess you have to pay for it um but but i think the easiest way to get started if you if you like the easiest road to entry is to just use chat gpte if you don't want to change your development environment, if you don't want to do anything else, just like the next time you have a question about something or the next time you're wondering how a diagnostic works,
试着问问 ChatGPT。我想人们会发现他们会开始越来越多地使用它，然后一旦你看到它对回答你的问题很有用，你就会更愿意尝试像 Cursor 这样的代理工具。是的，我会提醒一下，这只是它威力的一小部分。不过我要说，特别是如果你在使用 C++，并且遇到了一些模板元编程的编译时错误，我推荐这样做。这就是你真正会遇到的问题。
like try chat GPT. And I think that what people will find is they'll start using that more and more and then that they'll be more willing to, you know, once you see that it can be useful for answering your questions, then you're going to be more willing to try some agenic thing like cursor. yeah i would caveat saying that you're really not it's only a fraction of the power i will say though if it's especially if you're in c++ and you have some template metaprogramming uh compile time error that's what i would recommend it's like something that you're going to actually that's the problem
是那些……如果你是专家，你可能一眼就能看懂，对吧？所以，是的，但即使我能看懂，我也总是……我甚至不看，我直接把它扔给大语言模型，因为阅读它比这花的时间更长。我没时间做那个。我没有自尊心。但真正的威力在于当你
is those if you're an expert you probably know how to read that right away you know so it's yeah but even even if i do know how to read it it's like i always i don't even look at it i just plug it into the large language model because it'll take me longer to read it than. I don't have time for that. I have no pride. The real power though is when you
有一些你想构建或做的事情，你有测试，有构建命令，还有一个 building.md，所以你的工作流就变成了：听着，我要你构建这个功能。这是我想要的一个测试示例，再构建几个类似的。
have some thing that you're trying to build or do and you've got tests and you've got a build command and a building.md and so your workflow becomes, listen, I want you to build this feature. Here's an example of a test that I want and build a few others like that
我想要你做的是去构建它，或者写出代码，然后构建项目。如果有编译错误，你知道，不断迭代，直到……你甚至不需要解释得这么详细，你只需要说这是我的功能，确保它能构建成功，确保测试通过。然后当你处于代理模式时，它就会自动循环……你知道，巴拉巴拉。这就是我在本地项目中设置的东西。我有所有的 clang-tidy 铃铛和哨子，还有 clang-format，所以它做完这一切后，它会说，哦，让我去检查一下。它可能使用了一些 std::enable_if，这已经不再是最佳实践了，所以 clang-tidy 会说，哦，用 requires 代替这个，然后它就会
and what I want you to do is go out, build it or like write the code then build the project if there's compilation errors you know iterate until and you don't even need to explain it in this detail you just say this is my feature make sure it builds and make sure the test pass and then when you're in hygienic mode it just goes and cycles oh you know blah blah blah and that's the thing i have set up in my local projects i've got all the clang tidy bells and whistles clangforma so like after it's done all that it then says oh let me go check and so it might it might have used some you know stood enable if which is uh you know not best practice anymore and then so the clank tidy will say oh use requires uh instead of this and so then it'll
去把我的代码库现代化，用我脚本里的 dash-dash-fix。所以这太棒了，真的太棒了，伙计们。我以前在想到要设置另一个 clang-tidy 文件、让 Python 脚本正确工作、指向正确的地方、设置一套自定义规则等等时，简直要崩溃了。这就是为什么我认为 Rust 可能就是未来，所有这些东西都是开箱即用的。是的，你什么都不用做。一条命令就搞定。但无论你是 Rust 程序员还是 C++ 程序员，都试一试吧。
go it'll modernize my code base with a dash dash fix on a script that i got in so like you can start it's just so great it's just so great folks uh you know i used to i used to die inside when i'm thinking about oh i got to set up another clang tidy file get the python script working correctly pointed out the right things you got to set up a custom set of rules and whatnot which is why i think probably rust is just the future you know all that stuff ships out of the box yeah you don't have to do anything. It's one command. But still, whether you're a rest programmer, C++ programmer, give it a shot.
如果奇点发生，你可能只剩下几年时间了。是的。总之，最后的想法是……好吧，我想我得……接下来我要做的是去钻研 PowerPoint，因为我得敲定下周在 SciPy 上演讲的幻灯片。我很遗憾没有我的代理工具，因为我……我已经确切地知道我会写什么，我会写什么样的提示词。
You might only have a couple years left if the singularity happens. Yeah. Any, anyway, final thoughts from... Well, I guess I got to... The next thing I got to go do is go dive into PowerPoint because I got to finalize my slides for talking at SciPai next week. And I'm sad that I don't have my hygienic thing because I... Like, I already know exactly what I would write, the prompts I would write.
我只需要更新三张幻灯片。所以这就是我今天剩下的工作了。这太疯狂了。知道什么是可能的，然后现在不得不手动去做，感觉……这让我很难过。你就像是用一只手在写代码，你知道吗？是的，或者用一只手在做演示文稿。
I just need three slides I need updated. So that's going to be the rest of my day. It is crazy. Knowing, like, what could be possible and then having to do it manually now, it feels like... It makes me sad. You're, like, you're coding with one hand or something like that, you know? Yeah. Or building a deck with one hand.
是的。总之，这会是一集、两集、三集还是四集？谁知道呢。好吧，我不知道。你给这起个好名字了吗？我们要问问 LLM 吗？我本来想叫 AI Talk，但我不知道，我不想把人吓跑，因为我很确定有些人看到“AI”这个词就会选择跳过。
Yeah. Anyways, will this be one, two, three, four episodes? Who knows? Well, I don't know. You got a good name for this? Should we ask the LLMs? I was thinking like AI talk, but I don't know, I don't want to scare people away because I'm pretty sure some people see the word AI and they're like, skip.
是的，我不知道。我们现在是 AI 播客了吗？不，虽然我要说，如果谈话中不允许提到 AI，我会很难感到兴奋。因为有些领域，我不想具体点名，因为我不想针对这些人。但有些领域，AI 就像是一个触发词。所以我们不得不进行讨论，并绕开它。但我只是觉得，如果不谈论这可能是我们一生中最大的范式转移，那谈论任何事情还有什么意义呢？就像是，我在和谁说话？
Yeah, I don't know. Are we an AI podcast now? No, although I will say, I have a hard time getting excited about conversations where I'm not allowed to mention AI. Because there are certain, I don't want to be specific because I don't want to call these folks out. But there are certain spaces where AI has like, it's like a trigger word. And so we have to have discussions and, like, skate around it. But I'm just like, what does it even mean to be talking about anything, not in the context of, like, what is going to potentially be the biggest, like, paradigm shift of our lifetimes? It's like, I was, who was I talking?
前几天我和 Asher 在聊，编程语言现在还重要吗？显然很重要。但作为一个曾经的编程语言狂热爱好者，我现在发现自己对语言范式没那么在意了。我已经了解了很多那方面的东西，但当我可以让程序为我完成所有繁重的工作时，
I was talking with Asher the other day about do programming languages even matter now? Like, obviously they do. But, like, as someone who was a huge PL enthusiast, I now find myself caring less about language paradigm. and like I already kind of know a lot of that stuff but it's just like when I can get a program to do all the heavy lifting for me
嗯，你知道，我为什么要关心呢？我想要最适合那个工具的语言。如果那是 JavaScript 而不是 Python，我更喜欢 JavaScript；如果那是 Rust 而不是 C++，我更喜欢 Rust。你知道，这当然……
well you know why do I why do I care I want I want the language that's going to work best with that tool if that's JavaScript instead of Python I prefer JavaScript if that's Rust instead of C++ I prefer Rust you know like it's sure
我过去因为 X、Y 和 Z 的原因喜欢某种语言胜过另一种，但现在那是因为以前是我必须亲自打字和迭代。我现在不那样做了。是 LLM 在做这些。所以，在一个你正在构建库和语言的世界里，我觉得我们最应该关心的事情
I used to like one language versus the other for reasons X, Y and Z but now that was because I was the one having to do the typing and the iterating I'm not doing that anymore. It's the LLMs they're doing it. So it's like in a world where you are building libraries and languages, I feel like the number one thing we should care about
是它们如何与 LLM 交互。我们是在让事情变得更困难还是更糟糕？我一直在向很多人强调这一点，我们需要开始思考如何设计库、如何设计软件、如何设计文档，以便让 LLM 能够消费。是的，就像你提到 GPU 模式的人在做 Kuda 内核生成时，
is like how do these interact with LLMs. Like are we making it more difficult or worse? I've been making this point to a lot of people that we need to start thinking about how do we design libraries, how do we design software, how do we design docs to be consumable by LLMs. Yeah, it's like when you mentioned the GPU mode folks doing the Kuda kernel generation,
编写 Kuda 内核的表面积非常棘手。它的语法并不简单，它在处理这些东西时确实很吃力，这对我来说一点也不奇怪。所以如果我们打算构建某种下一代的、由 LLM 构建的 Kuda 编程工具，我们真的应该思考并尝试在幕后完成繁重的工作，确保我们发布到世界上的任何东西，LLM 都能很好地处理，既容易生成代码，又能高效运行。
it's like, well, the surface area of writing a kuda kernel, it's very thorny. Like, you know, it's got syntax that's not simple, and it's not surprising to me at all that it really struggles that stuff. So like if we're going to be building some next generation, you know, LLM built Kuta programming thing, it's like, well, we should really be thinking and trying to do the heavy lifting behind the scenes of making sure that whatever we're putting out into the world, LLMs do the right thing with it's easy to generate code and it also runs very efficiently you know
总之，这是另一个话题了。我认为编程语言仍然很重要，而且实际上，现在是编程语言领域一个令人兴奋的时刻，因为在未来几年，我们将看到为 LLM 设计的编程语言。这就像我们有了编程语言的新受众，现在我们需要思考的不仅仅是如何为人类设计一个好的功能，而是如何为 LLM 设计一个好的功能？从根本上说，人类仍然会与代码交互。你不能仅仅为 LLM 设计代码。我不认为我们处于那个阶段。虽然这是一个有趣的研究
anyways a topic for another day i think that programming languages are still important but and actually it's an interesting it's an exciting time to be in the programming language space because we are going to see in the next few years um programming language is designed for lLMs and just the the it's like we have a new audience for programming languages like now we need to think about not just how do we design a good programming, like how do we design a good feature for use by humans, but how do we design a good feature for use by LOMs? And fundamentally, humans are still going to be interacting with the code. You can't design the code solely for the LOM. I don't think we're at that phase yet. And I think while that's an interesting research
领域，我认为人们当然应该探索它。但我认为更实际的是，编程语言将成为程序员（人类）和 LLM 之间的交流接口。所以我们需要弄清楚如何构建代码，代码如何以一种人类和大语言模型都能轻松高效地交互的方式来组织。是的，我 1000% 同意。这就是为什么我说，当我进入一段对话时，我整天想的都是
area, and I think people should certainly explore that. I think that more practically, the programming language is going to be the interchange, the communication between the, the programmer, the human, and the LLM. And so we need to figure out how can we structure code, how can code be structured in a way where, both the human and the large language model can easily and efficiently interact with it. Yeah. I 1,000% agree. And that's why, like I said, it's hard when I enter a conversation and like all I'm thinking about all day long is
AI，我想在跑步时戴着 AI 眼镜，这样我就可以做更多工作，而其他人却说它很烂，它不起作用，它没用。我就想，我们生活在同一个世界吗？是的。总之，这会是一个……哦，还有。
is AI and like wanting to have the AI in my sunglasses while I'm running so I can do more work and then there's other people being like it sucks, it doesn't work you know, it's not helpful and I'm like are we living in the same world? Yeah. Anyways, it'll be a, oh also too.
一个小更新。不是特斯拉，我们没有买特斯拉。我们买了一辆丰田插电式混合动力车，不是因为我们反对特斯拉，而是因为我们意识到对于……我最终做了反对派研究，
Small update. To Tesla not to Tesla, we did not Tesla. We bought a Toyota plug-in hybrid not because we were against Tesla but because we realized that it's actually a better option for I ended up doing opposition research
因为埃隆，然后发现如果我们打算进行很多需要充电两三次的旅行，目前买一辆混合动力车实际上更好，直到我们有了快速充电设施。好吧，是的，是的。就像更便宜或者只是更灵活，所以选择了混合动力。
because of Elon and then discovered that if we're going to be taking a lot of trips that are, you know, are going to require two or three Tesla charges it's actually better to get a hybrid for the moment until we get fast charging. Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like cheaper or just like more flexible to have the hybrid.
更灵活，所以它不一定更便宜。我认为特斯拉充电仍然更便宜，但它会更灵活。特斯拉充满电仍然需要 25 分钟左右。而且如果你要去偏远地区，你不一定能用到超级充电站。
More flexible and like so it's going to be it's not going to be cheaper necessarily. I think the Tesla charging is still cheaper, but it's going to be more flexible in that. Tesla still take like 25 minutes for like a full charge. Yeah. And then also if you're going to like remote areas, you don't necessarily have access to superchargers.
特别是在加拿大，考虑到你要去偏远地区，我认为你可能会有更大的灵活性。我无法想象在加拿大的荒郊野外会有大量的超级充电站。是的，问题在于 Shima 有时会做偏远地区的住院医生工作，所以我们可能会开车六七个小时
Like especially in Canada and given that you're going to remote areas, I think you probably will have greater flexibility with like I can't imagine that in the middle of nowhere in Canada there's a ton of superchargers. Yeah, and that's the thing is that Shima does remote hospitalist work sometimes and so we might be driving like six or seven hours
去工作，我会在安大略省的农村地区远程工作一周，这可能没问题。但问题是，如果你处于混合动力模式，你可以把丰田普锐斯当作电动车来用。它有 80 公里的续航里程，所以如果你只是在城市里，你就把它当作电动车用，只有当你需要进行这些长途旅行时……然后你可以跑，我不知道，1200 英里还是什么的。
to work, I'll be working remotely for a week in like rural Ontario and it's probably fine but the thing is is like if you're in hybrid mode and that's the thing is you can treat a Toyota Prius as an EV. It's got like 80 kilometers of range so if you're just local in the city you just treat it as an EV and it's only when you need to do these trips that and then you can get like I don't know it's 1,200 miles or something
但重点是，听众更新一下，我们没有买特斯拉。也许埃隆能冷静下来，五年后我们买第二辆车时会重新考虑。他看起来不太可能很快冷静下来。听起来不像。我想他最近的一条推文是……
but the point is a listener update we did not Tesla and maybe Elon can calm down and we'll reconsider the next time we get vehicle number two in five years or something it doesn't seem like he's likely to calm down anytime soon doesn't sound like it I think his most recent tweet was
这很容易发生，这就是为什么我猜那个特朗普的模仿……我不会模仿埃隆。局势很容易升级，但我不会，我不会那样做。这真是一个疯狂的时代。好了，我们该结束了。
it could be very easily that's why I guess the Trump impression I don't have an Elon impression it could be very easy to escalate but I will not I won't do it it's like crazy time to live in All right, we should wrap up.
我们该结束了，因为这只狗得出去。请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。
We should wrap up because this dog has to go outside. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com, for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
那不是标语。我们的标语是“充满信息碎片的混乱”。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那不是我们的标语。我们的标语是“混乱中点缀着信息”。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。